68% des français sont favorables à une
baisse des allocations familiales en
tout cas pour ce qui touche les plus
riches le parti de ses 68 % pas ça
dépend quels objectifs on recherche si
l'objectif qu'on recherche c'est de
ramener de l'argent dans les caisses de
l'état c'est pas comme ça qu'on va y
arriver la bonne milliards d'ici 2016 en
tout cas c'est pas à la réalité puisque
de toute manière le le trou de la caisse
des deux familiales de la caisse
d'allocations familiales est censé se
résorber petit à petit donc de toute
manière la réalité qu'elle est il dans
notre pays c'est que maintenant on ne
parle plus que taper sur les riches ya
plus que ça qui compte
comme s'il fallait niveler mais c'est le
message politique le discours politique
de françois hollande d'une démagogie et
d'un populisme à l'extrême on ne parle
plus dans notre pays que deux des riches
des riches niveler tout le monde vers le
bas comme si maintenant l'objectif
c'était de vous dire tous pauvres et
j'en ai marre je vous le dis très
concrètement je suis exaspéré par ce
discours alors que nous devrions porter
l'espérance dire à nos jeunes
travaillent et réussissez progresser
tenter de devenir riche
plutôt que de dire ce systématiquement
c'est parce qu'on va les prendre aux
riches qu'on va résoudre tous les
problèmes
eh bien c'est faux je vous le dis c'est
totalement faux alors ne laissons pas
encore une fois stigmatisé en dix ans en
prenant riche on va résorber toutes les
caisses parce que c'est c'est totalement
inexact
en revanche mener des politiques de
baisse des charges vous savez que
aujourd'hui avec la politique menée par
la gauche
nous sommes au taquet de la pression
fiscale et c'est ça qui est intenable
dans notre pays c'est que les réformes
ne sont pas faites
la première réforme stupide qui l'ont
menée afin réforme c'est pas une réforme
c'est à dire de remettre en cause dès
leur arrivée c'est de supprimer la tva
sociale que nous avions fait adopter
avec le transfert de des décharges vers
la tva c'est à dire nous on baisser les
charges et augmenter la tva les augmente
la tva ils ne baissent pas les charges
et je vous le dis je vous le dis à votre
antenne ce matin ça n'est pas avec la
politique menée aujourd'hui que le
chômage va baisser à la fin attendue et
je vous le dis le chômage aurait eu ce
soir mais c'est clair on ne peut pas
créer d'emplois dans notre pays s'il n'y
a pas de croissance donc de toute
manière le chômage va continuer
d'augmenter et à la
de l'année contrairement aux mensonges
de françois hollande le la porte de
chômage ne va pas s'inverser c'est faux